thank you
uh is my microphone working
well i hope you can hear me so um i
i put a disclaimer up there i'm an
economist not a computer scientist
but there's a sense in which my talk
fits a little bit with proper cars
because
i'm going to be talking to you about how
when we think about
markets and maybe the computerized
algorithms that might help
organize them we think a lot about the
the behavior of participants in those
markets so
um so so we have some some similarities
there
um i'm going to mostly tell you about
markets and less about computers but but
let me
mention that one of the things i'm uh
the kind of economist i am
i'm i'm what's called a market designer
these days and
what we're seeing is more and more
markets that are
run by computers and uh the
the uses of computers in helping
organized markets range from the
the simple almost
trivial but sometimes with profound
consequences to the more complex
so i'll i'm going to emphasize one of
each
uh i'll tell you uh whoops that's not
what i wanted to do
do i have a laser here maybe maybe i do
maybe just a little i'm going to tell
you a bit about
how markets can be run on computers and
that makes them fast and that
has bigger consequences than than you
might think in terms of the behavior
that they elicit
i'm going to tell you about how i mean
one of the ways that computers interact
with markets of course is they make
markets ubiquitous we're we've all got
markets in our pockets now
um some of the ways we use computers in
markets is
as trusted intermediaries you can tell
things to computers that you might not
want to tell to other participants
uh and people have a uh it appears to me
uh surprising trust in software
and um and then sometimes we can do real
computations i'll tell you a bit about
that too
uh now now many of you know a whole lot
about
computers and markets and how how they
can be customized to very high degrees
so the whole idea of search and search
ads is that you can
uh start to commoditize uh very small
parts of the the
market space but of course not all
markets
resemble auctions i'm going to mostly
talk to you today about markets that
don't really
resemble auctions in the sense that
price doesn't determine
isn't the only thing that determines who
gets what so think about stanford and
berkeley and how they
fill their freshman classes they don't
run an auction they don't raise tuition
until just enough freshmen remain
uh to fill the class uh it's expensive
to go to
stanford or berkeley but it's it's not
so expensive that there aren't lots of
people who would like to go so lots of
people apply and then these selective
colleges select
uh who goes so they don't just rely on
prices to determine who gets what
and labor markets are like that too um
so these these are these matching
markets are a little bit like courtship
and marriage
in the sense that you can't just choose
what you want you also have to be
chosen right so you can't just uh
tell tell google that you want you're
arriving for work they have to hire you
and they can't just choose who to hire
uh they have to compete with facebook
and with
stanford uh so these are markets that
are that are matching markets where you
care
uh who you're matched to and there are a
lot of market institutions that are
involved in these
choices there are application and
admissions and selection processes and
interviews and uh you know how offers
are made and all of those kinds of
things
now i've been involved in in helping
design some of the
market institutions that do some of that
work and
the ones i'm going to briefly talk about
today
are uh the use the kind of algorithms
that that we've used to
to design medical uh labor market
clearinghouses if you have friends who
who are graduating from medical school
then they go through something called
the national resident matching program
that has
an algorithm like the ones i'm going to
be telling you about today
if you have friends who are putting
children into schools in new york city
in boston and denver and new orleans
they also use algorithms like the ones
i'm going to tell you about today
the the market design uses lots of
different kinds of algorithms so
so i don't want to over generalize what
i'm telling you about
uh i'll talk about very different kinds
of mathematics
but with some similar high-level
problems in uh
ec later in june if you're there
you'll hear me talk about very different
kinds of market and kidney exchange but
today i want to talk to you
about markets that use an algorithm that
i think will be familiar to many of you
i'll remind you about it
but it's the deferred acceptance
algorithm for which um
which is is something that david gale
who was at berkeley for many years
and lloyd shapley wrote about in a
famous 1962 paper
uh called uh college admissions and the
stability of marriage
and this is on the one hand it's a
computer sciency kind of algorithm i
think many of you will have taught it or
had it taught to you in classes on
algorithms it
arises in markets uh naturally that is
over the years as we've studied markets
and marketplace clearing houses and how
they're organized we've found many
independent discoveries of deferred
acceptance algorithms as people try to
organize their markets
and it's useful in some kinds of market
design which i'll tell you about
and again i'm going to i'm going to sort
of tell you about how it
interacts with markets both in problems
that you might think
are too easy to require computers but
turn out
computers tap to be very useful in in
helping out
and also in problems that are that you
might think are too hard even with a
computer because
the complexity theorem say that some of
the problems that we solve
you know as a matter of course are are
np complete uh
so you all know better than i how how
worst case
complexity doesn't always tell you how
hard things are and i'll tell you about
some of the difficult problems that that
are usefully solved
uh fairly simply so let me
briefly specify a simple model just to
to be precise i'm not going to do
anything very heavy with this
let's think about a simple model that
has two kinds of players in it who i'll
call firms and workers
uh i'll sometimes call them firms and
workers sometimes i'll call the firms
colleges or hospitals or schools
and sometimes i'll call the workers
students
but so so i make no promises about my
terminology because
in the different markets these things
show up i call them all those different
things
but the idea is that firms are looking
for workers workers are looking for jobs
that are firm
firms are looking for multiple workers
each firm has
a number of positions that i that i've
called qi
and each worker in this simple model is
looking for one position
and they have preferences the workers
have preferences over firms
they can tell which jobs they like
better so think of the the
wages already being incorporated into
the job description here
and the um the firms have preferences
over workers
and there's some point in their
preferences where they put themselves
which is to say
further down on my preference list his
worker jay further down
than myself i'd prefer to remain
unemployed for the time being rather
than
match to any firm i like less than that
and an outcome is a matching that
matches firms to workers and workers to
firms and
respects the capacity constraints
and so you might want to say what kinds
of uh
matchings might we see in such a world
or or if we were organizing a
clearinghouse what kinds of matchings
might we want to suggest
and one thing we shouldn't suggest
because we wouldn't expect to see it
happen
is we shouldn't suggest that anyone be
matched to a firm that they're not
willing to work at
and similarly no we shouldn't suggest
any firm that they should
hire a worker who they've already said
they would prefer to leave a position
vacant then hire
so i'll say a matching is individually
rational if it meets those constraints
if it only matches people who are
willing to be matched with each other
and then a more interesting thing that
could interfere with our ability of our
clearinghouse to suggest matchings
is if there's a worker and a firm who we
didn't match to each other
but who look at each other and say you
know how come we're
not matched to each other i like you
better than the job that i got and you
like me better than one of the workers
who you were assigned
and so if we're going to make the
mistake of of allowing these blocking
pairs we can expect that
that we won't see the matching we
suggested
actually occur because uh this is going
to be a world in which
workers and firms can freely contract
with each other if they
if they wish to and um incidentally
we'll talk about whether it's hard to
find a set of a stable matching or not
it's not in the simple model but it's
easy to check if you're part of a
blocking pair if you get a job with your
if i run a clearinghouse for doctors and
you get a job with your
third choice hospital all you have to do
is call up two places to find out
whether one of the ones you'd like
better
would be glad to have you so blocking
pairs
are easy to detect in the market if you
think of the market as a sort of
parallel computation device and we'll
say
a matching is stable if it's not blocked
by any pair of agents
so here's the famous deferred acceptance
algorithm which i
i suspect will be at least a little
familiar to some how many of you is the
deferred acceptance algorithm a little
familiar
great okay so so as i
i hoped uh so let me um let me
add some lines to it that you might not
add when you
teach it in an algorithms class i'm
going to start it off by saying workers
and firms
privately submit preferences so what i
mean by that is
everyone is going to write down a
preference list they're going to submit
it to the software but other
participants in the market won't see it
so in particular when you say
google is my first choice firm and
facebook is my second
and stanford is my third facebook is not
going to
see your preference list they will not
know that you
chose them second and they will not be
able to condition their preference list
on where you are
where they are in your preference list
okay
so people submit preference lists
privately
if some preferences are not strict i'm
going to uh
arbitrarily break ties uh and then we go
through a process that sounds like a
decentralized process and i want you to
remember that because i'm going to come
back to the decentralized process
but but right now i'm thinking of this
is going on in the computer with these
preference lists each worker applies to
his or her top choice
each firm looks at all the applications
it's gotten
it holds as many as it can up to its
capacity
using its own preference list to break
ties it holds its top choices
and rejects the rest up to its capacity
and it doesn't accept the ones it hasn't
rejected that's why it's called a
deferred acceptance algorithm
it it just holds them but it rejects it
immediately rejects the ones that can't
fit and the rejected workers go on and
apply to their next choices and the
firms then look at the
applications they've gotten to date the
ones they've held so far and the new
ones
without prejudice about when they came
in they order them according to their
own preferences the firm's own
preferences they keep the ones they can
and reject the rest
after they fill their capacity and this
goes on until
no workers are rejected at which point
the the each worker is matched to the
firm that's holding its application so
the the the acceptances are deferred
until the algorithm stops
there's of course also a firm uh
proposing version of this
where the firms make offers up to their
capacity
workers look at all the offers they've
gotten hold the
one they like best and reject the rest
and so forth
and gail and shapley prove two
remarkable theorems
the first is that a stable matching
exists for every
marriage market for every in this case
uh
college admissions market i should have
uh changed the
the word there um
here's the proof of that theorem what we
have to show
oh i i don't know if i emphasized no one
holds an unacceptable offer or makes an
application to an unacceptable offer so
individual rationality we get
for free what i have to show you is
there are no blocking pairs
so suppose i'm a worker in the worker
proposing deferred acceptance algorithm
suppose when it stops i'm accepted by my
third choice firm
how do i know that i'm not in any
blocking pairs how do i know that my
second choice firm which i would prefer
doesn't always
doesn't also prefer me well the fact
that i'm matched to my third choice firm
means that i already applied to my
second choice firm and was rejected
so although i would prefer to be matched
at my second choice firm they don't
prefer me we're not part of a blocking
pair
so a stable matching always exists and
in fact
when the workers propose you get a
worker optimal stable matching it's
simultaneously the favorite stable
matching for all workers
when preferences are strict and the same
is true
of the firm proposing algorithm it gives
the best
matching best stable matching for all
the firms simultaneously so that's
that's a remarkable theorem it's not at
all obvious that
the stable matching should have this
structure you think of the firms as
competing for the best workers and the
workers is competing for the best jobs
so when you ask me what's the best
outcome the best
outcome is that i should have my
favorite job i should work at google
and that might be everyone's favorite
outcome so we do not have there's not a
work or optimal outcome
but there's a worker optimal stable
outcome
because you rephrase the question you
say no no don't tell me
what's the best outcome what's the best
outcome in which you are employed by
someone who might actually hire you
and you say oh well in that case and now
everyone
points to the same outcome so it's a
remarkable result
there are some other results when i when
i started studying this i started
looking at incentives
and one of the things you can show is
that when the workers are proposing it's
a
dominant strategy for the workers to
reveal their true preferences to a
clearinghouse that's going to do this
so the question of is it safe to reveal
your preferences
it's going to be an important one in
market design because we can't get these
good outcomes that we can talk about
unless we get good information about
what people want and in order to get
information about people want when you
ask them
you know tell us your preferences
they're going to ask you what are you
going to
do with those preferences and if you
can't say to them
it's safe for you to tell me your true
preferences you may get
different information and and worse
results
now stability turns out to be important
for
clearinghouses when we started doing
this work years ago
we had a relatively small set of
examples that we could look to in the
world of places that had
invented clearinghouses that were either
stable
yes or no or or not yes or no
and we could see whether they were still
in use and we got a lot of association
it's a small data set but a lot of
association between stable matchings
and those that were still in use but
certainly not perfect
and laboratory experiments were helpful
in
in filling that gap that is there are a
lot of differences aside from their
algorithms between
you know cities like uh edinboro and
and uh birmingham uh i once gave a talk
to british uh medical administrators
and showed this kind of graph uh you
know back in the day and they said
and and what i wanted them to see was
that stable
matching mechanisms seem to work and
unstable ones don't seem to work
but the question i got was why do
computer why don't computerized
uh clearinghouses work in england
and i said to them pardon pardon me and
they said well you know edinburgh and
cardiff
they're in scotland and wales but you
know birmingham
so so that's not a crazy question right
there are other differences between
uh edinburgh and birmingham than the way
they organize their
medical clearinghouses and that's one of
the ways in which laboratory experiments
are very useful for us in thinking about
these things
but today we have a lot more experience
partly because of the work that my
colleagues and i have done so there are
lots of
uh successful stable matching markets
these all use
varieties of deferred acceptance
algorithms one of which i'll tell you
about when we get to the uh the problem
of couples
and the one i'm mostly going to focus on
today is uh
psychology internships in the u.s so let
me tell you
how they came to use a deferred
acceptance algorithm because when i
first started to study them they
what i want to tell you is how they came
to use a computerized clearinghouse
because when i first studied them they
had a telephone labor market that i'm
going to describe to you in gory detail
now
but the funny thing about this telephone
labor market was
hidden inside its rules and there were
elaborate rules which i'm going to show
you
was a deferred acceptance algorithm but
the labor market
was not producing the behavior that
today
it enjoys when it uses a computerized
deferred acceptance algorithm so part of
my what my talk today is about is how
come
two implementations of the deferred
acceptance algorithm should produce
very very different behavior of market
participants
okay so let me tell you about this um
they switched to a deferred acceptance
algorithm that i helped design in in
1998
but but i'm going to tell you about
studying them in the early 1990s
and what they did at that time was they
had a selection day it was the second
in in i think 1991 it was the second
monday in february
and people interviewed these are
clinical psychologists so they're not
md's but they
they're health care workers they they
try to make you feel better
incidentally one of the ways you know
that a market isn't working is the
trade literature of that marketplace
starts to have complaints about it
and different trade literatures have
different kinds of complaints
so when you look at markets for lawyers
the legal journals that talk about the
problems in the markets for lawyers talk
about are people following the rules
when you look at the markets for
clinical psychologists and they're
talking about how the market isn't
working well
the surveys they do ask people if they
found the market very stressful
so so these guys had a very stressful
market and the rule was they went on
their interviews
and then they sat by their telephones on
the second monday in february from 9 a.m
to 4 p.m central standard time
and they answered the phone they called
and answered the phone
and among the interesting things i
observed about this market aside from
that it was very stressful
was that it had they had previously in
the 70s they'd been running this market
for 20 years by telephone
but they'd been constantly making
changes and among the changes was
they shortened the time it had been a
whole week and then it had been
three days and that had been a day and a
half and by the time i looked at it it
was
it was you know one day uh
right it was uh seven hours uh
and so one question is why were they
doing that and was that the right thing
for them to be doing
so that's the mystery i want to solve
for you first so
i'm going to introduce the market to you
through their rules now
rules are i'm going to use them today as
an entertaining way of telling you about
behavior in the markets because
a good rule of thumb is that no one
makes rules against behaviors that no
one is exhibiting
the the second thing and this you could
see in the documents is the rules start
off
uh very terse rule one rule two rule
three rule four
but they end up more elaborated rule
three
a b c and the abcs get added year after
year
and and it's sort of to say when we say
that something isn't allowed
let's let's let's be more explicit about
the things that aren't allowed these are
things they're seeing
so for instance here's rule three that
says no internship
offers in any form can be extended by
agencies before the beginning of
selection day in the first version of
the rules it just said that
and then at some point you know item a
is added it says
the only information that agencies may
communicate prior to this time is
whether the applicant remains
uh under consideration the spirit of
this item precludes any communication of
an applicant's status
prior to the time above and then you
know they've other
rules the c said internship programs may
not solicit information
regarding an applicant's ranking of
programs we can't say to you
are we your first choice or her
intention to accept or decline an offer
of admission until the offer is tendered
and i put a little
ha next to that that's a technical
market design term
and it means that this this rule is
uh honored in the breach everyone breaks
it okay so
this is a rule that says we can't say to
you
in your interview by the way if on match
day
we were to make you an offer would you
take it are we your first choice
not allowed to ask that okay
rule four says applicants must reply to
all offers no later than closing time
uh and then you know there are added
rules like agencies
uh may inquire as to the applicant's
progress but you know under no
circumstances however may an agency
implicitly or explicitly threaten to
rescind an offer in a decision if not
made prior to the end of selection day
so you can tell these are rules that
reflect the fact that something about
this market is making people
nervous uh
but here in the middle is the deferred
acceptance algorithm
right really clearly this is the
deferred acceptance algorithm they say
this is how you should behave
you can the uh the title i put in that's
not
theirs but it says an applicant must
respond immediately to each offered in
one of three ways it can be
accepted rejected or held and applicants
may hold no more than one
active offer at a time okay and they
added some things to say they really
meant that so you can see that there was
probably going to be some problem with
people's behavior
certainly you can see how it'll be
tempting to not just
uh immediately reject an offer when
you've
gotten another one it might be tempting
to hold two offers for a little while
but there it is the deferred acceptance
algorithm
okay now then the rules that follow say
you know just what do we mean by an
acceptance so now there's lots of rules
i'll go through quickly but it says
an offer of acceptance to an applicant
is valid only if the applicant has not
already accepted an offer of admission
to another program
uh you know and then it says you know a
you know verbal acceptance is binding
before b before programs extend an offer
they have to
explicitly inquire whether the applicant
has already accepted another one you can
see that there are problems here
a program may in no way suggest that an
applicant renege on previously accepted
offers
so have you have you firmly accepted any
other job yet
you know um you know so so they're
clearly having problems
uh and then what happens at four o'clock
at four o'clock there's an aftermarket
so at four o'clock somewhere i said that
somewhere in there it says
uh you know at four o'clock all the
offices are accepted or that that are
accepted or done and all the
uh ones that haven't been accepted are
declined and
um but but there are still unemployed
people in unfilled positions at
four o'clock central standard time so
now they have an exploding offer market
applicants should be prepared to accept
or reject late offers quickly since most
other deliberations should have already
uh taken place programs may legitimately
place
short but reasonable deadlines for
responses to such late offers so the
smiley face
is that the world reasonable let's think
about what's been happening in this
market
at nine o'clock i call someone up and
and they've got till four o'clock i make
them an offer we say you know i say
this is al you know we we loved you
everyone loved you we want to make you
an offer
and you say to me great you know thank
you i'll i mean you might say i accept
but you might say you know i'll get back
to you i'm still hoping to hear from
some other places and i'm really
delighted and looking forward to the
possibility of working with you
so at ten o'clock you get a better offer
and
following the script you immediately
call me up and you say
al i got better offer and i say thanks
you know have a great life
and i call someone else right away and i
say to them
you know talk to you later here's the
offer i hope you accept
and he's supposed to let me know by four
he calls me back at
at three and says no thanks
and i immediately call my third choice
and i say
we've got an offer he's supposed to let
me know by 4. he calls me back at 3 30
and i call my next offer and i say
you've got half an hour you know you're
supposed to let me know by four
he calls me back at 3 55
and i call my next choice he's got five
minutes till four o'clock
and now it's after four o'clock and i'm
supposed to place a reasonable deadline
uh for responses right so so my previous
reasonable deadline which was determined
by the rules that was five minutes
no one gets to hang up on an offer after
the
deadline has passed they're all
exploding offers and of course
most of the calls that i'm going to be
making and this is where some of the
distress comes from on the parts of
firms
are going to be the people who say maybe
if i'm lucky they say you should have
called me earlier you know it's four
o'clock i just accepted
another job you're too late so that's
what firms are worried about okay and
then the next set of rules
are all about uh what to do if someone
breaks the rules
you know applicants who receive offers
that do not comply who you should
complain to and what the consequences
are
so so a couple of pages of what to do if
someone doesn't follow the rules
so these don't look like the rules of a
trouble-free market so i showed you a
bunch of
of names of markets so that i said you
know they're organized by deferred
acceptance algorithms and they're
working fine
but this one was organized by a deferred
acceptance algorithm not a computerized
one it wasn't working fine at all
so let me tell you some behavioral
observations from this market uh
first it was a really fast labor market
not computer fast
but really people fast offers took about
five minutes to deliver i sat there with
a stopwatch you know sometimes
rejections took about a minute right
they'd already decided who they were
going to make offers to they would call
up they'd already talked about the terms
if we make you an offer on this day
these will be the terms so
the five minutes was just chit chat you
know we really loved you
and the one minute you call me and you
say uh you know i can't take the job and
i say okay
thanks a lot and we immediately make a
call to the next person so
if you think about someone calls me up
to decline the job i'd previously
offered him that takes a minute
then i immediately get on the phone it
takes me five minutes to make an offer
so there's a six minute turnaround time
when we try to make offers for assistant
professors at you know in universities
you sometimes need permission from a
dean before you can
take a rejected offer and turn it into a
new offer right so nothing like that
here you know we're not talking a week
or a day we're talking
six minutes there was enormous pressure
on students
to indicate at their interviews and
before selection day
whether they would take an offer if
given it so the form of that question is
are we your first choice and there was a
lot of willingness by students to
say if they were a first choice the the
group of students that couldn't easily
say this were married couples who were
looking for two jobs together because
whether you're my first choice depends
on whether my wife gets a job near
you so we can take two jobs and we're
gonna have to wait for that so they
the couples felt that they were at a
significant disadvantage from all this
pressure to say
whether you were first choice because
employers paid a lot of attention
to who who they said were first choice i
remember sitting in
some of these call sessions on on
selection day and
the two directors would be there with
their multiple phones and they'd say
okay here's our plan we're going to make
offers to numbers
to in our rank order list to numbers 1 3
5 7 and 12.
and you'd say to them i thought 1 2 3 4
and 5 was your plan
and they said well that's our
preferences but 5 7 and 12
have told us that we're their first
choice so they'll accept immediately
so we won't have so three of our
positions won't be hanging out there
where there's that hazard that at the
end of the day even though we're a good
program
someone might reject us five minutes to
the deadline and then we wouldn't be
able to fill
so there was a lot of attention if you
said
that i was your first choice it made it
more likely that i would give you an
offer
okay so there's a deferred acceptance
algorithm going on here i just want to
point out to you that it doesn't end
like the deferred acceptance algorithm
the the deferred acceptance algorithm i
showed you ends when no one wants to
make any more offers
this one ends when time expires okay
and after time expires there's this
exploding offer market where
i'm going to model that as everyone
takes the first acceptable job they get
offered if they don't already have a job
so
that's straightforward behavior the
reason there are all these rules about
acceptances or binding is sometimes you
get offered a better job than you accept
it at four o'clock
and then you take that one too and then
there's all sorts of trouble
okay so an easy theorem i've already
proved it
is that if the time limit if seven hours
is like infinity
if it's enough time then we'll get a
staple matching
so you can already guess that seven
hours is not going to be enough time and
that's why there's a
a problem we're stopping this deferred
acceptance algorithm before it reaches a
stable match how can you investigate
that
i didn't have any better way to
investigate that than with simulation
and here's a simple simulation we ended
up running lots of different simulations
but here's you know 200 workers 50 firms
uh
offers take five minutes rejections take
one minute there are some other calls in
there but they turn out
not to matter these things are the rate
determining factor
uh let's see what happens when you're
when you run that with
five minutes and one minute which is
around what we observed in the market
the mean
time to terminate remember this is a
market with seven hours allowed to it
the mean time is is 18 hours
so it just takes too long now ninety
percent of the students have an offer
after an hour and ninety nine percent
have an offer after five hours so this
is a market in the simulation where
there are just 200 students it's about a
one-fifth size market
uh when 99 of the students have
offers there's only two students who
don't have offers
why is it taking so many hours between
the time when there's only two left and
and the end of the market well the
answer of course is they don't have the
right offers yet
so let's think what happens in this
market let's just look at the offers and
imagine
that you were looking at a map of the
united states from the air
and every time two guys are linked by a
telephone call
it lights up when you look at that first
hour
you see lots of lights lighting up just
all the lights light up everyone is
calling everyone
so here's my firm we have five offers to
make
so we get on the phones we've got two
phones takes five minutes to make an
offer sometimes we get a busy signal
sometimes we
we get turned down right away by someone
who we weren't the first offer that
morning and they
but pretty soon we've been making our
calls pretty soon
we put down our phones and they're
silent and what are we waiting for
well our offers are out maybe one's been
accepted already uh
we're waiting for people to call us back
with decisions so
even if we had a lot more phones it
wouldn't go any faster
okay so they were waiting and the market
undergoes a phase change instead of a
lot of
offers being made in the first hour many
fewer are made in each subsequent hour
so what's happened let's look at that
map of the united states
with the the the lights
indicating the the active telephone
calls in the first hour there are lots
of lights
but in the second hour there are very
few and what are they doing well
our phone rings and someone says to us
no thanks
and we immediately put the phone down
and call the next person on our list and
it takes us five minutes we say
ah you know it's been such a busy
morning sorry we couldn't get to you
before you're you know we
we love you uh you know come work for us
uh that takes five minutes then we put
down the phone
that's that's taken six minutes from the
time we got our
rejection to the time we've delivered
our new offer that means you can only
move 10 links on that chain in an hour
so
we went from a big parallel processing
lots of calls all going at the same time
to sequential processing all of a sudden
it's 10 calls an hour
moving around the country and there
isn't enough time in seven hours you
have to in this little simulation this
little model you had to make almost 900
calls to get to a stable matching
but but that could take 40 hours
so um so when you enforce termination
time
after seven hours they go to exploding
offers and that gets done much quicker
because now you don't have to
wait you know everyone accepts the first
offer they make but you end up with lots
of
blocking pairs okay that's not stable
because
sometimes you take an offer that isn't
the best offer you could have gotten you
might have already
and you might have taken an offer early
you know at four o'clock and a better
offer comes along
and of course as soon as people start
holding two offers for a little while
then the number of blocking pairs goes
way up so that's why there are all those
rules
if there's only a few chains around the
country going at
10 an hour and then one of them stops
because someone is
holding two offers he's holding up the
progress of the whole market
and and that can have bad consequences
so that's why they had all those rules
about you have to
promptly notify people and you can only
hold one offer and you have to answer
quickly
um so the conclusions for this market i
want to tell you some other things
are that markets can experience
congestion
offers take time so the deferred
acceptance algorithm is a polynomial
time algorithm
this was the fastest real labor market
i've ever witnessed it only took six
minutes
from a rejection to a new offer that is
astonishingly fast but not fast enough
so you can ask the question were these
guys mistaken remember i told you that
they had started at
five days and then they'd come down to
three days and then they'd come down to
a day and a half and now they were down
to seven hours
before they adopted a centralized
algorithm they went down to four hours
are they just crazy the market you know
wasn't long enough and they're making it
shorter
they're not crazy at all how long is the
market
well in that little simulation i showed
you it it should
have been it needed to be long enough to
make 900 offers
that's how long the market is how how
many offers can be made
so is five days longer or shorter than
one day
well they were getting six minute
turnaround when they had the one day
market
why were they getting six minute
turnaround because a seven hour market
was short enough that everyone could sit
by their telephone
that means when you called me i was
there and when i called you you were
there
when we when they had the five-day
market that wasn't true people had to go
to clinic they had to go to class
so the market looked five times as long
but if the response time went from six
minutes to 30 minutes
it meant the market would effectively be
shorter so every time you got an
answering machine that said
you know i'm really eager to get your
call and i will call you back as soon as
i can that meant
the market had become shorter in a
relevant way which is how many offers
could you get through
so they were trying to make the market
faster and they were doing it by making
the duration shorter in order to
compress the time now of course when you
go to computers you know they
they they now use a deferred acceptance
algorithm and it's
it process these things very fast let me
tell you one more thing it does i see
i'm
running out of time but this is a
computationally simple thing
it goes fast that really makes a
difference now it's a dominant strategy
for them to tell you
their true preferences it's not a
dominant strategy when someone says are
we your first choice
to answer truthfully because your first
choice may not really like you enough
for that to matter when you say it's
like applying early admissions to
college you want to use your your one
silver bullet
in a in a way that'll get the most bang
for the buck so you say
to the place that's most likely to care
and that you like
you're my first choice but now that they
use a deferred acceptance algorithm they
can state their true preferences that's
safe to do
so the other thing i mentioned earlier
let me tie up here a little bit is
is that there are couples in this market
people who want to get
the same uh vicinity you know husband
and wife who want to work in the same
vicinity
this is a problem we earlier encountered
in the much larger medical match but
that we've done a lot of work on for
for for this match now too and uh here's
an algorithm that was invented in the
70s not by computer scientists
um couples had to be certified by their
dean as a legitimate couple
and once they were certified by their
dean they had to specify one of the
members of the couple
as the leading member and the
leading member submitted both members
submitted a preference list just as if
they were single
and you know my first choice my second
choice my third choice
and then the leading member went through
the match and the
following member were had his or her
list edited to take away
places that weren't in the same city and
then the following member
went through the match this didn't work
very well couples
didn't take the jobs they were assigned
to that caused ripple effects
eventually it caused guys like me to be
asked to redesign the
match so why didn't this work well for
couples well
the iron law of marriage is that you
can't be happier
than your spouse so
so so think about think about me and my
spouse
we we consume pairs of jobs
right as a we're an economic agent that
needs
two jobs so our first choice might be
two jobs in california and our second
choice two particular jobs in california
and our second choice might be two
particular jobs in boston and our third
choice might be two particular jobs
somewhere else
so when they use this funny algorithm
where one person is the leader
that means we might get one good job in
california and one bad job in california
that's not what we wanted and the iron
law of marriage kicks in
so we'd rather have two particular jobs
in boston in that case
so we call up our the you know the
hospitals in boston and we say do you
have room for us and they say
why yeah you know we didn't think you
guys were available
because they they like us we're a
blocking pair we're we form with them
blocking pairs that are a little more
complicated now that we're a couple
then they call up someone else and they
say sorry you know we had a budget
shortfall we we don't have all the
positions we
expected to have we're not going to be
able to hire you so it ripples through
the
labor market so one problem
is they weren't asking couples for for
the right
form of preferences it wasn't an
expressive language to
to ask for their preferences what are
your pairs of jobs but it turns out even
when you ask for pairs
couples are a hard problem um
deferred acceptance algorithm isn't
going to work for couples because
think about the problem of me and my
wife apply to two jobs in california
and those jobs both like us better than
the other applicants so they hold our
applications
some people get rejected but not us then
some of the people who are rejected
apply for jobs and one of them applies
for the jobs that's holding my
application and my
potential employer likes the new guy
better than me so he rejects me
so now our second choice is two jobs in
boston
but my wife has to be withdrawn from the
job that was holding her application so
that the two of us can apply to two jobs
in boston
and that presents a potential blocking
pair it means the algorithm will no
longer be one pass
so it can be a computationally hard
algorithm
it turns out the set of stable matchings
may be empty and it's
np complete to determine whether it is
so so it could be a hard problem
um let me not give you examples of that
we
developed an algorithm to deal with it
it's not guaranteed to find a stable
matching because of course
one might not even exist it's not even
guaranteed to find one
when one exists but it always finds one
in all those many
uh labor markets i showed you it uh
it turns out not to be hard to find
stable matchings they exist and they're
not hard to find
so one puzzle
is how come you know why is this easy my
colleagues and i have been trying to
address this
by looking at the fact that although the
market can have thousands of employers
in it most people don't
apply to more than 15 because you have
to go on interviews first and things
like that
so it's a big market with short lists
which makes the
connection sparse in a certain sense
you can look at large markets that have
that
problem with not too many couples so
there aren't too many couples and the
length of
applicants rank order lists is small and
couples
have long rank order lists because they
are ranking pairs but they
they don't consist of that many
different jobs that they've applied to
there's just lots of combinations of
them
when you make a large random graph model
of that
i'm not going to have time to tell you
about it you find that in the limit
uh stable matchings exist so there's
there's some thought that that this
works well and what's going on there
is that when the market is large what
what makes what makes the
stable matchings fail to exist is that
the one remember it's not a one pass
algorithm so
some couples get displace other couples
and then you have to
try again what what makes stable
matching
fail to exist is cycles among couples we
displace you then you displace us
then we displace you those cycles turn
out to be rare and the reason they turn
out to be rare
is that in large markets with short
lists there are always going to be some
empty positions
so when someone gets displaced they set
in motion a rejection chain
and that rejection chain is much more
likely to end when someone
applies to a position that was
previously empty than when someone
bumps the original person out again so
that's that's the key element of the
proof
a corollary is that this particular
algorithm that elliot parentson and i uh
developed is
is more and more likely to produce a
stable match as the
market gets larger if the number of
couples doesn't get too large
there are a lot of open problems related
to this it would be good to have
theorems that weren't limit theorems
theorems that talked about in finite
markets how likely were we to find
stable matchings with couples
how about if there are lots of couples
we we know little about that
and of course the fact that this is an
np complete problem isn't very helpful
you're going to hear this from
economists all the time we don't want to
know about worst cases we want to know
about ordinary cases and of course there
are
smoothing results now i mean you guys
are doing better and better than telling
us the kind of results we need but
but not for this problem yet so let me
let me end with some concluding
observations
when what do marketplaces do
you know what do markets do well the
first thing a marketplace has to do is
it has to
attract participants it has to make the
market thick
it has to make people want to come to
the market so that they can do their
transactions there
and not do them elsewhere or not do them
at all or any of those things
another thing once you have a thick
market is you run into a problem of
congestion
there are a lot of people in the market
so there are a lot of
transactions to evaluate and might take
time to evaluate transactions or to make
offers that's what i showed you with the
psychology telephone market
and then you want to make the market
safe to participate in
safe to come to the market instead of
transacting somewhere else
safe to wait until the market opens
instead of transacting earlier
safe to reveal relevant information like
what your preferences are because we
can't give you what you want if we don't
know
and computer assisted marketplaces have
been able to help with each of these
right the the the trick to making the
psychology market thick was to dealing
with the congestion their big problem
was the congestion they didn't
they couldn't process all the offers
fast enough to get done on selection day
but of course with a
computer it's no problem it doesn't seem
like much of a problem anyway it's a
polynomial time algorithm
but it's one of these algorithms that
undergoes a phase change right it starts
off very
parallel and then it becomes very serial
and and seven hours wasn't enough
uh but on the computer there's plenty of
time once
you've made it uncongested you start
making it attractive and
you make it safe for people to to
to make lots of offers so they don't
need to know are we your first choice
so so we start getting better
information about the preferences
and the better and better the market
works the thicker it is the more people
wait to transact in the market instead
of trying to transact earlier
so so in and oh and of course couples
we made it safe for couples to
participate couples used to not be able
to use the results they got from this
market so they'd have to either transact
earlier or later
so in in ways both simple just speed
and profound you know a computationally
complex
computation about couples uh
a computerized centrally centralized
clearinghouse makes this market work a
lot better
than it did when it was a telephone
market thank you
why don't you recognize questioners
because i don't know anyone
questions what happens if your
references really depend on the other
person's preferences
yep what happens if your preferences
depend on how much
on their preference it can be tough i've
designed matches where that
uh is the case uh then we have to let
the people sometimes we have to let
people see the preferences
that kills the theorem that says it's a
dominant strategy to reveal your true
preferences so in particular
if i will not admit you into my freshman
seminar unless you list it as your first
choice
it's no longer if you want to get in you
have to list me as your first choice and
it might even i'm
although i might not be your first
choice it might be a good idea for you
to do that
so there are matches where that matters
and where it's important and we lose
strategy progress
so uh uh i'm a computer scientist in
academia
and the way that we
handle a new faculty
is more like that incredibly elaborate
scheme you described at the end then it
is like the gail shapley algorithm
is there a sociological reason why we
don't use
something like um
well you would have to um
get a you'd have to organize a lot of
people you'd have to get a lot of
coordination
the question was why doesn't computer
science use a deferred acceptance
algorithm to organize its job market
um the
you know hiring new medical residents is
a lot more like admitting graduate
students than it is like hiring faculty
because they don't have to come and give
job talks and things like that
so possibly it has to do with the cost
of developing a preference list as
opposed to
deciding here i'll use a computer
science we're deciding online
uh who to hire it's possible that you
you
preserve on interviewing costs by
interviewing people until you find
someone you like and then hiring them
it's also possible that uh that not it
would be hard to
organize everyone to do that you know
the the algorithm has a lot of appeal
because it produces efficient outcomes
that are stable
but i spent many years before i went to
harvard i was many years at the
university of pittsburgh which is a fine
university but not as
elite in the labor market as harvard is
and
over the years i was there we rose in
the reputational rankings quite a bit
and the way we did that is we hired guys
who were better than we deserved to hire
and the way reason we could hire guys
who were better than we deserve to hire
is
the the market was inefficient sometimes
a lot of people would cluster around the
the sparkliest candidates and we would
get guys who should have gone to some of
those better places but we made them an
offer and the market
closed before the better places could
make them an offer so we wouldn't have
been eager
in those years to go to a more efficient
marketplace because we were profiting
from the inefficiencies
another reason could be that for the
computer science job market
it could be that if my information is
correct and current
uh there is some kind of uh [ __ ]
mechanisms wiki
where people exchange so there may be
too much information
candidates exchange there's great
variety
about the way it's academic departments
hire in economics we have
centralized interviewing at a at an
annual meeting in early january
and then campus fly-outs but social
sciences
know if there's a natural extension
complementarities are tough and i
they're you know the natural extensions
the the the things i can
reliably guess are true is that those
look like hard problems and some of them
will be genuinely hard and some won't be
what i'm not at all good at
you know what you guys are but computer
scientists are good at telling us which
problems look hard
and unfortunately it turns out some of
those are nevertheless easy
so all these problems look hard which
partly means they don't have nice
mathematical structure
uh so i don't know much about that but
we do deal with complimentaries on large
scales
when we deal with say auctions for
spectrum radio spectrum where
packages have to be put together with
all sorts of properties
do you ever see markets and what happens
to your algorithms you put money in
equations
how about money well we often see
markets with money
well so no it was suppressed in the
analysis right what i what i gave you in
this analysis was
uh people have preference over jobs
presumably the money
wage influences those preferences so
what didn't happen what was absent in
the analysis here was
the adjustment of wages to help clear
prices
it turns out that's not a difficult
problem to add to this in other words
if you think of i mean even with the
discrete models if you think of money as
discrete you know to the nearest penny
then when i make you an offer i'm making
you an offer at a wage
and when you turn that down one of the
things i could prefer a little less is
to make you an offer at a slightly
higher wage and as the wage goes up i
might prefer to make someone else the
offer
so that so the the the simple
mathematics that i showed you
adapt uh trivially to having wages
with the couple's problem go away if we
had the firm proposing algorithm not at
all and the reason
it's a different problem right to the
with with the worker proposing algorithm
the problem is you have to withdraw
workers from firms
with the firm proposing algorithm the
problem is i get an offer
and my wife gets an offer in a different
city and now i get a second offer and i
don't know which one to reject i have to
i'd have to be able to look ahead and
see
what i'm looking for is a an offer in a
city where my wife has an offer so our
temptation
when you look at those and and there are
decentralized markets too our temptation
is not to reject anything until we start
to get a matched pair
right so i get an offer in boston and
then she gets an offer in st louis and
then i get an offer in
somewhere in wisconsin and she gets an
offer somewhere in missouri i don't know
which ones to reject because if she were
to get
an offer in wisconsin that would be a
good offer for me so the way those
algorithms fail is
we just accumulate offers until the
algorithm stops until there's no more
progress and then you have to make
people reject some offers
so no the problem looks different but
does not go away at all and of course
the set of stable matchings if it fails
to exist it'll fail to exist however you
organize
the algorithm how about the hypothetical
case where there is only one
hospital per city and
in other words i offer two couples now
and only
would this be a simple problem one
problem one per city i don't think
solved if there was only one hospital
that would make it a lot simpler
uh
how robust is
um
so the question is how do we respond to
threats and and we respond only
yeah we respond only naively to threats
uh we do worry you know with with
application system things like the
common application system for colleges
things like that
we do see lots more applications it's
getting cheaper to make applications so
without
without adversaries without without
malevolent behavior we're already seeing
that
applications themselves uh the fact that
you apply to my university
conveys much less information than when
you had to hand write a letter
uh applying so the
the expressions of interest are become
less reliable so for instance in the
economics job market we've instituted a
signaling mechanism it's easy to apply
for 100 jobs but the american economics
association will now
facilitate the transmission of two
signals uh prior to the interviews two
signals of
of interest and that the evidence
suggests that that's working to
to break some of the coordination log
jam
now how do we stop people from that this
is where we thought of attacks how do we
stop people from sending more than two
signals
you know we require them to use the
email address that they use on their job
market cv which we can normally find on
their
department website there's no point
signaling to someone under an alias that
they can't figure out who you are
uh so given that they have to be able to
interview you and that there's a system
set up for communicating those
interviews we think
that that uh that no one is
is pretending to be two different people
um but that's sort of
relying on on real methods of
identification that themselves might be
subject to attack
but i think that's not something we've
we've thought
about as much as you have one of the
exciting things for computer scientists
about market design of course
is that you get not only to design the
markets but you might get to design the
agents
and um so that will you know the the big
lesson of market design is
strategy sets are bigger than you think
and
all sorts of behaviors show up you know
if on another day i could tell you about
markets for lawyers lawyers earn their
money by
by thinking about ways to get around the
spirit of the rules while
obeying their letter so so we often have
to think about
attacks there
one more
so in large markets that problem becomes
small
thank you